stop asking people if they forgive you when you're apologizing to them
because it's shitty and it's manipulative
and I will tell you why the purpose of an apology is not to garner forgiveness
it's to show accountability
meaning you understand that what you did was shitty
and you are recognising to yourself that it was shitty
and you're letting other people know that you know that it was shitty
that does not require someone to forgive you
and in many instances you are not deserving of forgiveness
if during an apology
you are asking the person you're apologizing to if they forgive you
you are now putting the responsibility
of absolving you of your wrongdoing onto them
which they cannot do and if they don't feel like forgiving you
you are making them very uncomfortable
because you can absolutely move forward with a relationship in a positive way
without forgiveness
and this is especially important when you're apologizing to your kids
because they shouldn't feel obligated to absolve you of your guilt
a great way to pose this for children when you're apologizing to your kids
if you've acted a fool is to finish the apology like this
hey child of mine
I'm sorry for doing this shitty thing
I shouldn't have done it I recognise that it's wrong and you didn't deserve that
I will try to do better in the future
because that wasn't how I wanna handle myself
can we move on from here or should we have more of a conversation about this
so you feel okay now you can reword that however it feels natural to you
but asking a child do you forgive me
is trying to put a bow around a messy situation
and it's okay for all of us to learn to stand in our own mess